- I was running through
the 6 with my woes.
Do you know what that means?
The 6 is an area in Toronto.
And woes...
I'm James Davis.
And this is Swagasaurus.
Woes means your crew.
Your woes are your squad.
When you first hear Drake
claiming he was with his woes
it's easy to assume something
sad or woeful is going on.
Maybe he's just being
Emo Drake again.
Maybe woes is just
a personification
of the rapper's emotions.
But really, the word stands for
working on excellence
and represents a
brand of friendship.
Woes aren't merely
acquaintances.
Your woes aren't just
any group of buddies.
Woes are stand up individuals
who are primed to
accomplish goals
and win as a team.
Just because you're in
a class with someone
or you're friends
with him on Facebook
doesn't make them a woe.
To be someone's woe,
you all have to be tight
and have a history
or significant bond.
Matt Damon and Ben
Affleck, they woes.
Hell, Ben and Jerry,
the ice cream guys
they got to be woes too
cause their ice
cream is on fleek!
Jed Apatow, Seth Rogen,
Jonah Hill, James Franco,
they're each other's
woes and all they do
is make funny movies
with their woes.
And you know how that shit goes.
I'm starting to feel like
everyone who checks out
Swagasaurus with me is my woe.
We hang out.
We talk about women.
We stare at my jacket.
It's amazing.
It's friendship.
It's woeship.
I couldn't do this without you.
I can't wait to holler
at all my woes next week
with a brand new word.
And remember,
you're my woe.